What possessed you to want
to swim around the entire UK?
How many thousands of
miles is that? Yeah. Uh,
2000 miles altogether to a
thousand miles of swimming. Yeah.
Yeah.
It seemed like a good idea at the time.
And then half way round I realized
how big Great Britain was. But you,
you've done some long swims before
but not like nothing even remotely.
Like what's the longest swim you
did before this? I did. Um, I,
this is a bit of a
strange story. I did. Um,
I tried to swim between Saint Lucia
Martinique to Caribbean islands. Um,
it's only 40 kilometers
from point to point. And,
and for charity I was trying to swim,
uh,
from point to point with a hundred
pound tree attached to my trunks. Um,
so I was pulling the hunch of Pantry,
a six foot waves crashing down and,
and I actually didn't make
it from point to point.
I was like five kilometers from the end.
And when I didn't make it,
I decided to swing back the other way.
So I ended up swimming over a hundred
kilometers with a hundred pound tree.
Took me 32 hours, but still
didn't make it. So, so what,
what went wrong where you didn't make
it? Tides currents, you know, and,
and I use get swept away. Yeah. Yeah. And
it's usually attached to a tree. Right?
How big was this tree? A. So a
hundred pounds. But I mean it floats,
but it was more of the drag.
So if there's any influence from tidal
currents and it's pulling you in one
direction, I mean, I was basically
going to Miss Martinique,
so I know I was heading to Cuba,
you know, somewhere like that.
And then on the way back down, and they
turned to me again and they said like,
you're going to miss St Lucia,
you're going to end up in whatever's
further south than Saint Lucia. Um,
and I think I realized this as physically
fit as you are. Um, the ocean just,
just doesn't care, doesn't care. And
so after that, this was last year,
this was November last year. Um, kind
of felt I had unfinished business with,
with the ocean and came,
but came back to England,
a rung up from friends of mine at the
Royal Marines. I said, guys, look,
this is going to sound so
strange. I said, but I just,
I need to get out of my system.
I just need to see how far I can swim
in 48 hours. So I swan 40 hours. Um,
I can't remember. It wasn't, yeah, I
think it was 160 kilometers, something,
something like that. And I finished
and I had basically trench foot.
So where your, your, your feet
and your hands are. So kind of,
I've got so much water in. This one was
going moldy, you know, he's like, yeah.
So I had transferred, I'm sort of
sitting there, nursing, nursing my feet,
and one of the, one of the offices, uh,
a good friend of mine and they came over
and they just said, they went, you know,
real English, Royal Marine.
They said, you'll boy. And I
said, yes. And they said, oh,
what do you, what are you
training for? And I said, uh, Oh,
I'm training for a potentially attempting
the world's longest current neutral
swim.
And then just paused and he,
he sits his cup of tea and he
looked me up and down. He just goes,
that just sounds a bit lame. I was like,
okay, what would you want me to do?
And he pauses and he says,
you just need a manner.
We need to man up and swim around Great
Britain. I was like, Whoa, I can't, I,
I couldn't say no once the [inaudible]
said, why don't you swim with me, bitch,
did you do it mother fucker?
That's a crazy thing for someone
to be asking you to do. Now I know.
So I said, fine. Once the idea
stuck with me, I mean, you know,
we've got this real history and heritage
of a British eccentric explorers.
And for me growing up,
there's a story of Captain Web.
So the first guy to swim
across the English Channel,
and for those who don't know English
Channel, uh, you know, the tides,
they believe what? We're too
strong. The water was too cold.
They said you just can't make it across.
The English Channel isn't possible.
But captain web refuse to listen.
And 1875 August across
the English Channel.
And this is the part I love on a diet
of beef broth and brandy in a woolen
wetsuit.
He swam,
I think it was 23 hours breaststroke
with his head out of the water because,
and I quote,
front crawl was ungentlemanly like and,
and there was that element that I just
thought, that's amazing. Front crawl,
what is the front crossbar?
So, so basically that's
front the regular one. Yeah.
But way back in 1875 it was like, no,
that's Sarah's and gentlemanly. Yeah,
it was the movement itself themselves.
Yeah.
It was still being developed as
a technique. Whereas, you know,
if you are a gentleman and you were a
swimmer, you swim breaststroke, you know,
exactly. Head out of the water the whole
time, the whole way. 23 hours. And again,
like th the, the, the support boat we're
saying, you know, get out. You're not,
you're not going to make, you're not
gonna make it. And he just refused.
And 23 hours. So you know, that's
part of a night swim as well.
Had out the water just all the way.
Why Brandy?
Is he getting fucked up or just a little
bit of branding, you know, I don't know,
maybe it might have been
a bit of Dutch courage,
but I think there was certainly back
then sports nutrition isn't what it is
today.
So I think there was an element,
he was even like a lubing himself up in
goose fat, you know, this is way back,
make them soft, slicker, slicker.
And I think there was an element
of warmth for that was the,
certainly the belief, right? So
it was the Tour de France guys,
didn't they drink wine? That was like a
big thing back in the day. Way Back. Yeah.
I mean it wasn't too long ago.
Me and Jamie was just, just,
just talking now about football
back in England. And it wasn't till,
you know too long ago, I don't,
maybe a hundred years ago.
They used to just keep brandy in the
dressing room in case you needed to warm
yourself up real and out. Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
So they play soccer drunk there.
Yeah.
Kind of just slope with a
little bit something. Exactly.
All in turn it over. Wow.
Wow. And I think, you know,
people don't understand that it's taken,
you know,
people like captain web maybe me to a
smaller extent to just raise the bar,
push the boundaries and,
and you know,
you've seen that I think our generation
have seen that. Um, with the UFC,
with mixed martial arts,
that has evolved so fast.
I'm always remember Forrest Griffin
used to kind of a likened himself to the
basketball players just shooting three
pointers with the ball between the legs.
And that always resonated with
me because I was like, yeah,
the evolution that we've seen and what
sort of Bruce Lee had the foresight to
predict is amazing. And I think in
a, in a much, much, much smaller way,
again, to go back to sort of
British athletes and adventurers.
Roger Bannister in a first night's wonder,
a four minute mile and
people said couldn't be done.
And he was a medical student at the time
leading physicians that he can't do it.
Your lungs will explode, your legs will
fall off, all sorts. Um, but no, he says,
you know,
Oxford laced up his trainers and ran a
four minute mile similar right now to
what I think we're seeing with Kip Shogi,
you know, and the two hour marathon.
And so that's why, and again,
in a much, much smaller way,
when I had that conversation about
swimming around Great Britain,
everybody said it can't be
done. Yes, it's 2000 miles.
But there's giant whirlpools in Scotland's
called the Chorea Vecan Penland firth
renowned around the world.
If you get that wrong,
you'll disappear in backwards at 10 knots.
You,
there's no way you're swimming against
that and 10 knots, that's a dolphin speed.
She's, yeah. So what is 10 knots in miles
per hour? Basically 10 miles per hour.
10 miles per hour backwards as you're
trying to go forwards basically. Yeah.
Penn inverse of the top of Scotland,
the currents that go across there.
So it's running at a good clip, but yo,
yeah. Yeah. I mean we got it good. We, we,
we managed to basically
predict it so well that I,
I think that was probably my top speed,
which I did 8.7 knots.
It's 8.7 miles per hour. I was basically
cruising along the top, which is wow,
was just like a dolphin.
So you were having the waves behind you,
pushing you almost.
And see now that's what's interesting
because I had the tides and currents with
me, not necessarily the way I said
it wrong and when you get bit,
but actually you made a good point in
terms of when you get Windover tide.
So if you've got 10 knots going this way,
but he even got a little bit of
wind and waves going this way,
it can get choppy again.
And again,
sort of looking at west Scotland,
Windover tide,
you can get 40 knots coming
straight down the barrel,
but you're trying to swim with the tide.
Yeah.
The wind is coming at you,
but the tide is going the opposite.
And as you can imagine
that, oh my God. Yeah. Yeah.
So how do you predict this,
this,
this tide that you have to
get right? Yeah, I mean, it's,
it's in completely in theory.
And this is what I realized when I sat
down and we started sort of plotting the
great, what does this called again? What
is the issue that will push you back? Oh,
just the title. Yes. What
is it called? That area. Oh,
you say you got to get right.
Oh, so Penn Unferth pending earth
or the panel and for Pendleton for,
yeah. Yeah. And that's that,
like I said, renowned around
the world. But, but equally,
if you imagine the shape of Great Britain,
there's all sorts of kind of compression
where the water would just come rushing
through. And as well as the panel
and firth, you can get, you know,
six knots around whales.
There's an island called Scoma.
And if you get that right,
you are disappearing, you
know, and you're winning,
you get it wrong again, you're
going backwards. And for mile,
for me to do a continuous stage swim,
if I'm going backwards,
I've got to start where I was
going backwards. So for me,
getting every single tied right. And
that's while so for the team were amazing.
There was uh,
uh,
the Captain Matt was just incredible
that every night the homework,
are we okay here? No. Do
we crash? All right folks,
if you're listening or watching,
we had a little technical difficulty,
so this is not streaming
live will be uploaded later.
We were just going over how
you predicted you had to end,
your team had to predict how the tide
was coming because if it went wrong you'd
get pushed backwards at like 10 miles
an hour. Yeah. Basically. And the,
and this is the thing,
I think with the great British swim,
we were kind of taking swimming as
most people understand it and we were,
we were removing it and putting it
in an arena that was so different.
So I think that's why it was,
it did so well kind of online as well
as the community around it because
obviously swimmers were interested,
but you know,
surface started to get involved because
they understood the waves. Um, sailors,
fisherman, you know, all sorts of
people started to say, you know,
sometimes in Great Britain it's not
safe to take a boat around the top of
Scotland in it, for instance,
nevermind a swimmer. Um, so that's,
that's why it was amazing that, that
on the entire series it became, uh,
a melting pot and exchange
of ideas because nobody
knew how to get a human body
around the coast of Great Britain.
It wasn't just about swimming and,
and that was what was really
cool. How do, how do they know,
like when the tides are
going one way or the other,
how do they predict that tied
to so predictable? So in theory,
they change every six hours. So in
theory, when we sat down and we looked,
and we know that if you do six
hours on six hours off for 157 days,
you'll make it around the coast of
Great Britain. You know? And, and,
and that was the theory.
So you do this by phasic sleep
and you swim for 12 hours a day.
But that's all theory. There's times when,
as I mentioned, a giant whirlpools or,
or the tides might not necessarily,
if you imagine sort of that's Great
Britain there the tides out necessarily go
always like this or they're
not that predictable.
Sometimes if there's kind of like this,
like that's kind of whales,
they're the tides will do this.
So you're doing all these different
things that people are not going to see
instead of listening to it on audio.
So just try to just describe it. Right.
It's a basically rather than the is just
going up and down and working with you.
Sometimes they cross cross.
Yeah.
So you'll just kind of getting slapped
across the face. My tides essentially.
And it's not just helping you,
you're going to basically zigzag all
the way up the coast of Great Britain.
So it was predictable as tides are.
We found those so much stuff that
when we're out there we were like, oh,
it wasn't meant to do that. Or a giant
whirlpool wasn't meant to be there,
you know? But it is an, and
that was what was pretty, yeah,
pretty sketchy. It, sometimes you
need that when we were out there,
if it whirlpool just decides to appear.
You've got you,
there's not really enough time to say,
oh hang on, that wasn't on the map.
Can we look at that? Can we speak to
the Met Office and talk about, you know,
weather reports? No, you just, you,
I've had to swim through it or try and
get out there as quick as you could.
So when you encounter something
like that and you get stuck,
do you pull out of the water and try
back again later at the same location?
You do. But quite often if it was
there, it's still going to be there.
So it's just, it is what it is. Yeah.
So sometimes there's this notion and
perhaps the best example of this, um,
I mentioned for, it's called
the Chorea Vecan. So, uh,
sort of west coast of Scotland and
it's a giant whirlpool. And, and Matt,
the captain turned to me and
said, look Ross, you know,
I need you to swim and I need
you to swim hard. You know,
you need to spend six hours. You just
need to be clear of this whirlpool. Um,
so as we were swimming past it, I set
my watch and some hard for six hours,
but about three hours in,
um,
I got stung by jellyfish and I've
been stung by jellyfish a lot before.
He's just, you know, it's painful,
but it was, it was bearable. Um,
but this one particular
jellyfish, it just, it was
searing into my skin. It just,
it wouldn't stop throbbing.
And so I carried on swimming,
three hours passed and
it was just unbearable.
So I popped my head up and I looked at
Matt, the captain from the boat. I said,
ma'am, I'm so sorry I've been stung.
You know, I'm going to have to stop. Um,
I've been stung by jellyfish pitch.
The pain's just not going away. And as,
as I said that to him, he looked
down at me and he said, yeah, I know,
cause the tentacles still
wrapped around your face.
So I'd basically been swimming for three
hours with a jellyfish on your case,
wearing a jellyfish.
It wrapped into my goggles.
So I took my gold unpeeled this
fat tentacle threw it away.
Um, and then like I said, I'll
show you in a minute. I'll ever,
there was a picture where my,
my face sorta change shape and the
goggles wouldn't fit on my face anymore
because my eye sockets were so
swelled. Um, but I knew that again,
for all of this happening,
the Cory of Eq and the giant Walpole
was still to my left. So Matt was like,
you still need to swim.
You still need to sue them.
So I ended up paying the goggles over
my face and to try and get them to seal,
I just punched them into my face.
So you just had these perfect
ring and then I managed,
you're sore. Swollen. Yeah.
So you're a push them through the
swelling basically. Yeah. John.
So you swim. Um, I made another hour.
We got clear the Cory of Atkins.
We managed to clear this giant whirlpool.
I collapse onto the boat and, um,
and this is the thing, it was at that
point that I collapsed exhausted face.
Now a different shape to when I
started that particular swim. And, um,
and the team looked at me and they saw
how bad I was, how being an upper was,
but they also knew that,
that the sea just doesn't care.
And in six hours the tide was going to
change and I'm not going to have to do
that all over again.
And it was that kind of brutal
lesson from nature that,
that from a sports science background,
I'm interested in, you know, Rehab, rest,
recovery, nutrition
strategies, all of this.
But with swimming around Great Britain,
it very quickly became apparent
that the sea just doesn't care.
It just doesn't care that you
need to rehab your shoulders.
It doesn't care that the ligaments and
tendons in your shoulders are hurting.
You might get impingement from
swimming too much in none of this.
And that's why it went from swimming as
I understood it and how a lot of people
understand it to something completely
like surviving basically in the water.
So you're swimming schedule would be six
hours on and then you would try to rest.
When would you eat, uh, during the
swims or, or between Erin? The swims?
Yeah. Yes. Uh, quite often just, you know,
throwing bananas at me and
just multi bananas basically.
Yeah. Yeah. Just so deep and I
need to eat. And while you're
in the water. Yeah. Wow.
Yeah. Cause cause again going back to what
we were talking about with the pen and
firth, you could get out and
you could get on the boat,
but sometimes in a really good tide,
if you are just in the water,
you could be making four knots.
You don't have to swim.
But if you get in the freezing cold
water Scotland and you are quite happy to
getting hit in the face by 10th
cause you can still make four knots.
And so that's why so often it became
about something different than swimming.
It was just, it was just mental for
tutors, physical fortitude. It was um,
basically, I always remember actually
the first day of autumn, um, I got up,
it was two o'clock,
so it was a nighttime,
two o'clock in the morning and I left my
wetsuit out to dry and I had to scrape.
It's just a thin layer of ice off the
wet wetsuit before I could fit it.
But if I didn't, if I didn't get in and
I didn't spray it that, that, that way,
then that would have been,
you know,
15 miles potentially that
we would have missed out on.
And if you miss those 15 miles,
that the window of opportunity to swim
around Great Britain because of the
British summer being notoriously
unpredictable and quite short. Um,
we wouldn't have made it round because
even towards the end there was two storms,
a store Mallarme and
storm Cali Allien Callum,
who kind of stopped us for those two
days where we couldn't swim because you
just couldn't swim in a storm. It
wasn't safe. So when you were swimming,
this was all during the summer?
Yeah, yeah. Uh, for the autumn.
And then we finished November the fourth,
which was going into the winter as well.
And you started what month? Uh, June.
The first. So for, since June you've
been swimming? Yeah, basically.
God Damn Man.